what's up my name is Alex car pauses
presentation director at Ubisoft
Montreal and this is Rainbow six tech
support first question will tuck her ass
does anyone know how to get a custom 5v5
going in Rainbow six siege trying to
practice with friends and we can't
figure it out so we'll what you do is
you go to the playlist section of the
game at the very bottom you'll see
custom game click on that then you'll be
able to play with all nine of your
friends set it up the way you need to
set it up and keep on playing
next question from Ross Lindsay hello is
there any access to the guns in the game
in an Adobe Illustrator or Photoshop
file format I'm a graphic designer
and would love to make some skins any
advice would be great thanks for all
your hard work guys we don't have any
files but if you go into the full screen
view of the weapons you can kind of
Center them the way you want to and then
take a screenshot and go crazy with your
awesome photoshop skills next one the
only go queue that can't be only one
Goku will there ever be an operator with
dual pistols or is that a bit too unfair
for the Rainbow six siege community this
is something that we always think about
but when you start thinking about dual
pistols you now have to introduce this
entirely new way to play the game we
have thought about a character dual
wielding we have never prototype did yet
though not yet it's a really cool idea
don't know if we'll ever get there in
the near future
Aiden root nor in us is Rainbow six
siege getting an area 51 map soon it on
the area 51 map was cancelled it's not
going on sorry my Thai ass hey so
Rainbow six game what's up with this and
it's a picture of a parking lot so we
redid the way we light our characters in
our menus and this is what's called a
cube map so the cube map is the baked in
reflection you see in characters
if you look at Yeager's goggles you'll
see this reflected in them and it's also
a way to light characters as well so you
see those massive lights going down the
center of the picture
those are creating lights on the
character so it's just a techy way of
lighting the menu of our game DZ easy
ass can you elaborate how the placements
now work after the rank reset is it
based on your last season highest MMR or
your last ending MMR and is it still
halfway to 2500 when you finish a season
we take that MMR and then you do your 10
placement matches and combine that after
that we do kind of SWAT you in between
2500 and wherever your MMR is so if
you're at 3500 we'll slot you in around
3000 I hope that makes sense
next question from most-wanted legend
Rainbow six game what was bomber and T
hunt removed rest in peace bomber was
removed from T hunt because we wanted to
make T hunt a little bit more applicable
to training for a match you want to jump
in you want to practice and warm up you
don't want to be tripping over barbed
wire and facing off a bomber who's not
really involved in the online game
next question from Final Cut gaming has
there ever been a list of everything new
you can get in alpha packs yet the
answer is no what we do is every single
update we change the contents of the out
alpha pack and it's up to you to find
out what we've changed
next question from Jack buck is the best
operator in Rainbow six siege changed my
mind
Jack I don't need to change your mind if
you're not wrong question from mr.
cookies how many maps are in rainbow
succeeds every game seems like a new map
I have no clue what's going on
help so let's answer the first question
there's 20 maps in rainbow 6 siege and
it's one of the most difficult thing for
new players to learn is the map so what
we've done is we've introduced the
newcomer playlists so that's only four
maps jump into that playlist you can
learn it
learn those four maps really well and
they're actually part of our ranked
playlist as well and then we have our
ranked playlists this season we've
knocked down the number of maps in that
pool from 18 to 12 so there's fewer
they're more competitive and hopefully
that'll help you learn those Maps
well change every season so yeah
hope that helps next one from mr. hey
Juan Rainbow six game so if ash got to
elite uniforms could this mean that any
other operator can get a second uniform
for example bandit or smoke that's a
really good question mr. halen someone's
been paying attention and why stop there
why only two elite uniforms why not
three we'll see next question from mr.
Hoffs Rainbow six siege players what do
you use for your lien key binds me
myself personally I use the default it's
CUNY super simple but you can do
whatever you want on PC just make sure
that you can still strafe and move at
the same time Wilson says hey suggestion
for a control improvement being able to
disable the auto reload when out of ammo
it currently overrides weapon swap on
occasion and it hurts shield ups already
have it by default why not everyone this
is actually a really good question we'll
talk about it know what we'll talk about
it game be dear Rainbow six game barbed
wire is a gadget deployable shield is
the gadget drone taken over as a gadget
- why do they not count for destroying
gadget challenge then so game beat
there's two types of gadgets in the game
one is the operators ability gadget the
other is the secondary gadget that you
can customize in your loadout when we're
talking about challenges they're only
counting the operator ability next
question Sam yuxun asks anybody else
think the bolt and shield needs to be
balanced before actual launch gadget is
way too overpowered right now what we're
seeing in the test server and now that
the season is live it's actually pretty
good we'll keep on monitoring it we'll
make sure that boyo is where he needs to
be in terms of his Vulcan shield bonsai
clips
Rainbow six game is there a possibility
we will ever see a map interaction such
as opening closing doors or garage door
buttons or able to shoot something down
to kill an enemy also can we get an
operator that uses decoy grenades that
emits gunshot sounds as a distraction a
lot of questions there all right
Banzai will we ever see map interactions
maps are very difficult to learn so
although while it's a kick-ass idea like
its it's a good idea adding interaction
adds another level of complexity that
you have to learn on maps so we have
nothing planned for that right now about
a operator using a decoy grenade that
emits gunshot sounds that's actually a
really good idea of Rainbow six you rely
so much on hearing that this could be
really exciting but we'll keep you
posted
not a millio ass Rainbow six game are
you guys ever gonna come out with a
three year operator bundle four
operators in year three we wanted to
find out a different way of packaging
the operators so you won't see them in
an operator bundle
unfortunately mat row ass rainbow six
game sorry silly question there's no
such thing as a simple question how do
you apply for test servers to be a part
of it is a PC only that's great question
Matt because we always love people
jumping into our test servers and try
and stuff out it is PC only so if you
own the game spark up Rainbow six you'll
see a test server version of the game
right next to the official version jump
into that test out the game see you
early content and let us know what you
think Rob Walker asks I really want to
see Rainbow six teams go towards seven
man rosters almost similar to rugby subs
or changing lines in hockey have a
specialist for a map or strategy versus
an opponent swap them in between maps to
finish out a series this is actually a
really cool idea I guess you're gearing
it more towards the pro scene where they
have these dedicated lines of players
unfortunately it doesn't work out the
same
if we take hockey for example you're
switching out entire lines
Rainbow six is a really deep and
commutative game where you have to keep
on talking to the players you have to
know the call-outs that they're shouting
you have to know them really really well
you want a good group of players who
know each other to compete if you're
swapping somebody out and in usually
like a sub then you literally want them
to have the same knowledge as the person
that you're replacing them with so
that's probably why you don't see in the
pro scene so much then Wilkinson says
thoughts on next season having a k-9
unit operator thinking would be very
very cool dog emoji then this is
something that we've talked about for a
while our creative director mama always
talks about a k-9 unit but to answer
your question I have to ask you a
question are you okay with shooting a
dog that's it everyone thank you so much
for your questions and keep on sending
them to us because hey I'd love to see
you next time on Rainbow six tech
support Cheers